i started i couldn't breathe ozark can
get pretty dark so it's no surprise
there are moments the cast struggled to
film from awkward animal encounters to
emotional monologues the show has been a
roller coaster let's check it out number
one
frying pans who knew right
julia garner didn't realize she was
bringing the weight of her character's
burdens home with her she said that for
the entire first month of filming the
first season it felt like i was getting
hit by like a frying pan the energy
among people behind the camera is not
heavy though so she's able to escape the
headspace just a bit she's found it
easier to compartmentalize her life from
her characters as they filmed the
subsequent seasons but it still takes
her a bit to shake it all off
number two a woman's gotta do what a
woman's gotta do janet mcteer's
waterboarding scene is more real than
you might have thought she refused to
have a stunt woman stand in for her and
said it was a kind of fun yet exhausting
experience
imagine having a towel with cling film
on your face for that long you know what
cling film is right that stuff you wrap
your food with presumably they used it
so she's not
you know actually being waterboarded
while one hand was seen on camera the
other hand went unseen so that she could
signal the crew if she needed a break
the whole bit took three hours to film
that's a long time to be damp and in the
dark for
number three for some doing nothing
would be an amazing thing
not for poor nelson benia though the
most challenging moment for him happened
in season three during the therapy scene
with mary louise burke who played sue
shelby have you ever had a dog before he
was really excited to dive into the work
and explore the character when the
director alec pulled him aside and asked
him not to express a thing
the challenge was if we see any emotions
from nelson you lose
but i don't want it
while the scene looks great on screen
nelson wasn't feeling so great
off-screen poor nelson
not acting definitely won't win you an
emmy
number 4 a completely realistic phobia
julia garner is so petrified of rodents
she couldn't even watch the movie
ratatouille so when it came to filming
for ozark she actually couldn't complete
a scene the one where her character
needs to hold a mouse by the tail it
freaked her out so much she went into a
panic mode and they had to get a hand
double to do the shot
while a real mouse is a reasonable thing
to not want to touch she couldn't even
hold a toy one the worst of it was the
whole crew was laughing at her which
not cool guys people were sending her
pictures of mice for a month even
thinking about it just makes me cringe
number five they're scary and
intimidating if you're not used to it
julia garner has basically no experience
with guns on or off screen so her
inexperience showed in their first take
when the gun went off while she was
holding it pointing towards the ground
she screamed and the weapon was so loud
shaky and heavy that her wrist was
actually hurting by the end of filming
that scene she was genuinely surprised
it was as heavy as it was
number six taxi drivers must have the
best stories the initial reading of tom
pelfrey's stream of consciousness taxi
monologue had the actor in tears it was
written specifically with him in mind
and was written in one shot with like no
edits tom broke down into tears and
struggled to keep reading because he
couldn't see the words
he and the director avoided talking
about the scene leading up to it because
it was so stream of consciousness they
didn't want directorial influence maybe
pushing tom the wrong way the filmed
scene went off without a hitch they only
needed four takes of it because the
actors had the words so ingrained and on
the last two takes the director asked
him to just slow it right down while the
group watched it while it was still in
editing at first everyone in the room
was so blown away you could hear a pin
drop that was quickly followed by a
standing ovation
i get it thank you
number seven it's important to take a
little me time carson holmes could not
have fun before the shooting preparation
demanded bringing the energy way down he
even avoided talking to people you
really
there's no
funness kind of i know that sounds bad
but he's not the only one though in
order to de-stress and not get sick
after the fact the actors all needed to
spend some time rebalancing themselves
tom pelfrey said at some point the body
does not tell the difference between
authentic emotions and those expressed
through acting he gets lots of sleep
does yoga and walks his dog to shake the
energy laura linney likes to be alone
leading up to a big moment just to stay
in the appropriate headspace the last
thing she wants is to let anybody down
and the stress of that is intense
she's talking about the kinds of scenes
she says require an enormous amount of
emotion very quickly under a tight
technical requirement
number eight what is it with this show
and water michael mosley plays the
preacher chris young in season one but
he wasn't the first to land the role
somebody else was initially cast in it
but they dropped out pretty much at the
last minute so within a couple of days
mosley found himself in the role and had
to fly out to join the cast and crew for
one particular shot he continuously had
to walk himself out into freezing cold
water shot after shot after shot he was
wearing a wetsuit beneath his clothes
but we're sure that didn't do much good
they only had three pairs of clothes so
every time they did a shot he'd have to
go get changed so wardrobe would
immediately start drying his wet clothes
while he did another take and don't
worry the real babies never touched the
cold water
number nine no accent is easy unless
it's your own julia garner stayed in her
missouri accent for days to make sure it
was totally ingrained for filming just
so i can be familiar this role was a
struggle for her mostly because her
character ruth is the exact opposite of
her which made it really hard to relate
to ruth and her circumstances but of
course that didn't stop garner from
winning an emmy for the role but merle
be happy to sell a slightly used for
cash would he not number 10. perhaps the
exhaustion made the scene better the
hardest scene for julia garner was with
co-star laura linney dubbed the wolf
scene what made it so tough is it was
the night after her big emmy win and she
had to be up at 4 45 am it was her
biggest scene of season 3 and she
couldn't help but think
well it's all downhill from here
are you gonna do
number 11 the actors are on to greener
pastures now jason bateman really
struggles with scenes where they had to
kill off characters because that doesn't
just mean the end of an arc for a
character it means the end of a job for
an actor and a shift in dynamics on set
and he loves his co-stars and not seeing
them every day after spending all this
time together is just straight up sad
number 12 this one wasn't painful for
the reason you might think no no jason
bateman still had all of his toenails
when the day ended but don't get us
wrong it was still painful not on his
feet but his face
they started with the close-ups because
they knew what would happen if they did
it the normal way bateman was going to
blow out his voice screaming and he
totally did
so starting with those close-ups meant
he was able to take it easy at first and
then really give it his all when they
did the wide shots to close out the day
my life is good it sounds like the cast
i'll need to take a nice little trip to
the spa and just relax a little don't
you think which of these stories shocked
you the most let us know in the comments
and thanks for watching